can a computer replicate a visual system
yes can it replicate memory yes can it
replicate processing power of course
it's clear computers are better at us at
chess will a computer ever create a game
like chess it will get to be an
approximation and the question is is the
approximation at some level equal to The
Human Experience of Consciousness hey
Brian it's really great to be here with
you it's always great to be with you and
uh it's just lucky to have you as a
colleague and friend here in San Diego
yeah yeah it's been great um so hey
everybody's talking about artificial
intelligence and some people are talking
about it with great excitement and some
people are talking about it with a lot
of fear and everywhere in between how do
you see the role of artificial
intelligence especially in shaping or
even redefining the epistemological
foundations of science like let's say in
fields like astronomy where data is huge
and abundant but often needs you know
sophisticated interpretation it's so
hard for for me to decouple the just
outright joy and fun and pleasure that
I'm getting from AI Explorations and
experiments you know from the legitimate
concerns that I think you know people
need to be cognizant about it's uh it's
kind of a threat and uh and an
incredible uh an incredible toy and and
opportunity for so many of us especially
those of us with either children or
those of us with uh you know education
children that we get to teach I really
loved it it's been kind of uh almost
like getting to redo the internet boom
of the 9s for those of us that are old
enough to remember it but didn't really
participate in in kind of the the
shaping of it I was too maybe young at
the time but uh but but nevertheless
this is kind of a new opportunity when
uh we have an opportunity to shape the
future of Education of research of
scientific searching for answers and
Truth uh but but also redefining what it
means for us to be human beings and
fundamentally I think people lose track
of the fact that because of our my
colleagues are so otherworldly brilliant
that they actually are not human beings
but the the the the truth of the matter
is science is done by scientists and
scientists are human and we have all
sorts of wonderful qualities we are
inquisitive we're imaginative we're
curious we love to you know kind of
research and and play around and we're
also like children in another way we
don't like to share our toys we love to
claim credit and get attention and we
like to have the shiniest new thing on
the Block and so AI is all of this at
once it's a tool it's a helper it's a
it's it can be sort of um you know
dominant in in what we're doing and my
question is how do how do we get it to
serve us you know you hear a lot that
you know AI isn't going to replace your
job you know somebody who knows how to
use AI is going to replace your job I
actually don't think that's true
especially in the in in the professorate
you know which is my occupation um I
actually think we're completely immune
from Ai and and that's a shame I think
that's a that's a true uh failure of
Academia more than anything else to
adapt and adjust and and recognize how
challenging the future may be when an
afai can be brought online in a well
aligned way with a with a theological
purpose to improve the educational
outcomes for our students that make educ
ation more affordable more accessible
more democratized um for a greater
number of people because I believe the
only way to really uh have any hope for
Humanity's distant future any way that
we could last even you know a tenth as
long as we've been on this planet which
is only you know quarter million years
uh the only way we can get to you know a
fraction of that is by really pacing in
a in a proper way our technological
understanding of the cosmos so I'm
excited about it I think it's it's one
of the most um kind of an
energizing aspects of you know
technology that's come along in a long
time I I think we've only scratched the
surface of it and I'm excited to really
apply it to really at some ways you know
make my current job Obsolete and and
maybe we'll get into ways I think we can
do that yeah that's great I feel a lot
of the same ways you do my dad is a
scientist and when I was growing up we
were really early adopters and you know
we had the gigantic VCR with only one
movie you know at home and the you know
Apple 2 well I think we had the
Commodore 64 you know we had the Apple I
right so I mean like we were adopting
everything early on so when I first
heard about AI I was like this is
awesome you know and at this point I
keep it open on my browser pretty much
all day and I don't use it really to at
least the chat GPT form of AI I should
say I don't really use it to copy and
paste from but I definitely use it if I
get stuss you know right writing
something or thinking about something
and I founded just a great springboard
and almost like a partner you know it's
like data in Star Trek you know I would
I wouldn't take a data if I could have
one absolutely 100 per. so that's great
uh let's go to the positive side first I
mean the positive side like you were you
know you work in astronomy which is
massive massive massive data sets we
also know that um medicine for example
there's a lot of problem now of AI being
able to assist in detecting disease very
early from these massive amounts of data
that it's just very very impossible for
humans to be able to synthesize that
much data quickly yeah I think you know
having having access to a you know a
device that has the entire Corpus of
human knowledge and uh instantaneous
recall and just incredible synoptic
capability to cross reference all the
knowledge that's ever been generated I
think it'll be almost a form of
malpractice for you know Physicians not
to use it for Pilots not to I fly little
planes around Southern California and
you'd be terrified to know that not only
in my little
Cessna but in the 737 or whatever you
fly in to go to a conference on
Southwest Airlines you would not believe
the technology that's in the cockpit is
from the
1960s uh some of it's earlier 1940s the
fundamental radio Transmissions that
guide and communicate they have not
changed at all and so what happens in a
cockpit and I'll only speak to this I'm
not an expert in you know I'm not a
physician even though I'm a doctor you
know not I'm not I would say I'm not the
kind of doctor that helps people uh
maybe helps people learn about science
but but there's a pilot sitting in the
front and you know when they before they
take off they're they're getting this
information from a control tower and
only one person can talk or listen at a
given time it's a oneway one you know
Channel communication the biggest
airports in the world doesn't matter one
person talking to one other person if
there's an emergency in another plan no
one will know about it it's terrifying
then you're getting to the airport and
there could be like a you know a a plane
that popped a tire on the runway you
won't know about that uh BEC for about
an hour uh because it takes that long to
report back there's no live monitoring
and then furthermore you have to sit in
the cockpit and twidle a little rotary
knob dial in a discret frequency on the
uh FM radio dial uh that only Pilots can
access in their Aviation cockpits and
then when they get to the station then
you have to wait a minute to hear the
loop of the of the recording of what's
going on at the airport and all this and
you have to take your eyes off the
outside world as you're flying and the
controls I'm sure if people are scared
of flying they're going to be more
scared now but it's 100% you know right
for our automation as is you know having
a you know a data you know like uh you
know the movie her it's great movie you
know in your earpiece the doctor should
have that because the patient will be
talking and the patient's looking up at
the ceiling and the doctor's looking at
you know her computer typing in a bunch
of notes they're not looking at each
other and there's tons of non-verbal
cues that are being missed that a camera
might pick up or you know from subtle
Things That No human can pick at the
gate how they walk in you know how are
they uh how are their you know pupils
dilated when they mention things has
their skin temperature all this stuff
and it's just going to waste all this
information and not to mention uh you
know whenever I you know sit up in in
bed I get this pain in my left pinky toe
again I know nothing about medicines
okay so you sit up in bed you get a oh
that that's you know synops disease and
you know that's fatal 100% of the time
if not diagnosed and the doctor oh don't
step on that toe don't sit do a situp
anymore uh but you know computer can
then synthesize all this knowledge
provide a synopsis of it deliver it now
there is an impediment to all of this in
aviation especially and I imagine in
medicine as well and there entities that
are um you know that are humans they're
called lawyers and a lot of this
progress in aviation is styed by the
fact that if uh if there's a lawyer
involved there's an accident involved we
live in an extremely litigious Society
so Innovation is stifled and despite the
fact that there being net tremendous
Savings of lives and Aviation and and
just overall safety culture and and near
misses counting as accidents you know
just avoiding those altogether in the
medical world where it's prevalent as
well and we're just not doing it and
can't help but think it's because of
something very very non-technical called
lawyers I mean you bring up a really
good point which is that there is this
incredible ability to
synthesize but there is the risk that it
ends us up with the lowest common
denominator right so you're someone who
values both consensus wisdom and
non-consensus insight how do you
reconcile the potential of AI to either
enforce existing biases in scientific
research or on the other hand introduce
non-conventional methods that could be
game-changing yeah I mean that's that's
one of the things that I've really been
playing around with early on in the AI
Kind of Revolution which is only like
eight months old uh I mean I was playing
around a little bit with it um and I've
always been interested in it I've I've
talked many times with sir Roger Penrose
who wrote the emperor's new mind which
talked about computers and minds and
brains that was the first popular
science book I ever read and and
1989 when I was in high school didn't
understand it then still you know
struggle with it today but talking with
him about what is a brain what is a
computer what is intelligence what is
imagination has been just just
phenomenal for me and I've always been
interested in that even though I study
you know astrophysics and the origin of
the Universe I think ultimately they are
related at some level but one of the
things I play around with the most are
these you know scientific co-pilots and
and tools that allow me to to read and
to uh extract information and I don't um
I I don't use them when I construct
lessons uh for the primary lesson what
I've been doing is despite the fact that
UCSD has the best students in the world
some of them come in even in advanced
cosmology and they'll you know they'll
have some lacune in their understanding
of some Topic in in electromagnetism or
special relativity just something they
might have covered three years ago maybe
it's not so fresh everybody needs a so
what I'll do is there are these tools
and I'll use Ai and just generate a
whole bunch of slides with the bare you
know kind of minimum or partial
differential equations of special
relativity of Maxwell's equations and
electricity and magneti just synthesize
those into a slide deck no it's not
mandatory it's not part of the main
class but now I can have access to these
students they can have supplemental
conversations with these documents you
can now have a chat bot that basically
for each of one of my keting
supplemental you know uh strategy
lectures they can then chat with it and
they can interact with it and that's
been a lot of fun another thing I've
done and to synthesize you know I would
say to synthesize consensus uh but to to
understand how it's possible that you
can um at least come up to speed with
maybe an adversarial point of view
science is very adversarial the
scientific method is one of natural you
know hopefully good-natured uh
antagonism but but nevertheless you
should you know especially in fields
where human lives are at stake it's
something that's very precious and you
need to be careful with so what I'll do
is will take an um a database of of
writing from great old Works which I
think are still pertinent and relevant
today and I've started to try to make um
interactive chat Bots with the entire
you know book of Galileo galile who's my
intellectual and scientific hero and
mentors me from beyond the grave and the
way that we do this is I have access
through the University of California
which you know allowed me to use the
rights to Galileo's dialogue the
translation of it and I made the first
ever audio book of that book with my
friends Carlo relli and uh Lucho pillo
and it's a it's a play I mean you're
basically three characters over three
days interacting with well trying to
figure out is the earth the center of
the universe and now we just take it for
granted although I'm asking you I'm
looking at you not you Cassie but I'm
looking at the audience right now I'm
saying could you prove standing on one
leg that the earth goes around the Sun
it doesn't look like it to me uh looks
like that bright yellow thing is moving
around us so challenge yourself don't
just accept this accepted wisdom and
that's another thing I use these CH you
know talk to me like I'm five and and
prove you know uh that the earth goes
around the Sun and these are things that
you know people just take for granted so
I took the works of Galileo digitized
them they were digitized and
Incorporated them into a large language
model so we have the first you know
chance to chat with I call him galile
iio so artificial intelligence Galileo
and interacting with him over over the
centuries and you're having this
conversation as Carl Sean said a book is
proof that humans can work magic because
you're having a conversation with a long
dead author that was a book you know he
never lived to see podcasts like mine
where I've had his wife and his daughter
on but uh he's never you know he never
lived to see an interactive chat bot and
so now we can have Carl Sean bot and we
can talk to him and ask him questions
not just scientific things but also use
him as your research assistant but
simultaneously as your research mentor
and these are things that I think we
need to as Educators incorporate and
inculcate before it's too late because
the academic model goes back even
farther the one that we are using today
at UCSD that you and I use with our
students is a thousand years old it's
500 years older than Galileo it goes
back to the University of bolognia Italy
in the year 1080 almost nothing has
changed it's a sage on a stage and you
and I taking a piece of Rock and
scraping on another big piece of Black
Rock and the students are fawning you
know and they're you know they're not
getting any update Galileo could walk
into our classroom right now and he
would recognize exactly what we're doing
it wouldn't be like you know there's
some mystical orb glowing and
transmitting knowledge holographically
no no no it's just person scraping on a
rock that's all we've come up with in
the 500 years since he was born it's
crazy right so I I I really do think
that that it's R for disruption I'm
hoping to be a part of it uh but it but
it's uh it's exciting and energizing at
the same time hey friends just a short
request to ask you to use your thumb
while my thumb is occupied to leave a
like on this video and don't forget to
subscribe it really helps us with the
algorithm now back to the episode and
then when you think about teaching I
mean do you think AI can ever replicate
the sort of nuanced approach that a
human educator brings to teaching these
complex subjects
it's or Miss are always augmented yeah
yeah I I find it very Hit or Miss um not
just the hallucination problem which is
which is truly a problem you know I I
like the hallucination at sometimes
because I'll ask you know tell me about
Brian keading and I'll say he wrote
losing the Nobel Prize and um and he
wrote Into The Impossible and he wrote A
Brief History of Time and uh you know
I'm like no you know one of those things
is not true but then you need to figure
out like now you need an adversarial
chatbot to check on that chatbot so
there are things that are that are
challenging and and obviously
unacceptable you know for use and and
you know kind of these objects are
larger than they appear you know in in
the on the screen as a threat to you
know blind application of it but on the
other hand it does allow for the the
processing and and and sort of the
synthesis of of a tremendous amount of
historical knowledge where it's bad and
I think that I am an AI you know
optimist in in that I don't worry about
things like the the so-called paperclip
problem that uh you just going to
optimize and maximize you know my friend
Michael Shermer always says you know you
drive a Tesla it's it's got autopilot
which is an AI enabled um interface and
and driven by not a language model but
by you know artificial uh intelligent
engine and machine learning and Machine
Vision Etc and it knows you know I'm
driving he's driving from Santa Monica
to Santa Barbara and the quickest route
is actually to drive across the you know
to drive across Malibu Bay and you know
drive on the sidewalk and mow down some
pedestrians but it doesn't do that um so
you know optimization has to be sort of
shephered and I always point out the the
one statement to me I know you're
writing a book I can't wait to read it
about imagination now Einstein said a
lot of things one of the things he said
is imagination is more important than
knowledge I always say you know like
that's great but I don't want my you
know my surgeon to say oh I'm GNA try
this creative new procedure when I when
I give you the Brazilian buttlift or
whatever I'm going right you wanted to
like use knowledge not wisdom or not
imagination on the other hand he also
said that his happiest thought was when
he envisioned himself freely falling in
an elevator or in a out of a building
and in so doing that he would experience
no gravitational force and I always
point out the chances or the the
likelihood of a computer a understanding
Happ
and like why that was kind of giving him
a sort of pleasure and how that pleasure
was connected viscerally to the
preconception of falling that led to
this creative imaginative breakthrough
is uh is is almost imposs you can
supervise you know making not not
hallucinating but you can't supervise
that creative emotional thought so I've
been thinking a lot about that uh I feel
like it's not as much of a threat as
sort of the doomsayers musks and so
forth are are stating it to be and I I
think that they look at things as an
engineer and they really don't look at
things from a physicist point of you we
have to look at the exchange of energy
and balance of of resources we have to
look at physical limitations those are
the only laws of nature that are
inviable uh instead they kind of look at
it as you know like there's going to be
some kid in a hoodie in in Palo Alto and
and she's going to be you know just Pro
programming away and and turn us all
into paperclips so it's very different
when you look at things from a physical
limitations perspective versus an
engineering possibilities perspective
and I think we need both yeah yeah I
mean I think the big fear right the
biggest fear is that AI would you know
AI I would come senent you know that you
and I first met when we talked when we
were working on we were talking about
Consciousness together and so you know
if you look at biology and humanity and
reality from a very mechanistic
perspective then you think then the
brain is just a very complex computer
and we're worried that this other even
more better complex computer will
somehow enslave us or will somehow start
talking to each other and decide you
know we've been given the task of making
the earth a better place and the obvious
number one way to make the earth a
better place is to eliminate Humanity
that kind of are they brains are brains
computers are they are is AI conscious
could it ever become conscious there are
open questions I think first of all you
have to recognize that there is no real
understanding of Consciousness among
conscious entities like us uh there are
people that suggest that everything is
conscious there have talked to people
like that um and there are people that
suggest that you know Evolution has
produced a sensation of Consciousness
but it's not necessarily real the
so-called hard problem of Consciousness
is is you know coined by one of my past
guests David Chalmer and and basically
you know suggest that these qualia the
experience of another individual is
impossible to uh to understand to
replicate and and these things go back
way before David Chalmer I mean their
famous essay 1971 by Thomas Nagel was
entitled what is it like to be a bat and
the answer is I don't know and neither
do you and this you know 52 years ago so
the the question of what is
consciousness and rather the question of
can a computer be conscious is uh
impossible in my mind to Define before
we understand what Consciousness is so I
just stick to easy things like you know
special relativistic astrophysics but I
I I I think there is a you know there's
a quality and a qu and a quantity to
neurological processes to conscious
processes certainly you could have like
this incredible
experience of of you know kind of
equinity and so forth and be meditating
uh but then if you have no memory if if
you literally have no short or long-term
memory what does that mean uh is uh so
is that that entity conscious and then
if you only have a memory but you really
don't process the the state of awareness
of stimuli or conversely if you're
overwhelmed by the stimuli like if you
have ever done this You Close Your Eyes
uh you know you think oh I want to close
my eyes everything's goingon to be dark
so everybody out there close your eyes
and then notice as you're closing your
eyes that there's a tremendous amount of
lightlike
Sensations that you're actually
perceiving and yet the your visual
system is completely shut off um you can
even do this in a completely dark room
you could go in outer space and this
will happen what what is that what's
going on there I mean there's so many
different processes so there it's all
awareness and you're aware of it but you
know again you have no memory of it or
if you only memorize it and just like
you cannot you have this Persistence of
Vision in your Acuity in your visual
field and you cannot ignore things you
could also go kind of crazy and then you
know what level do you have
Consciousness there so now can a
computer replicate a visual system yes
can it replicate memory yes can it
replicate processing power of course um
I always say you know it's clear
computers are better at us than at chess
uh but you know I can beat a computer
half the time at Tic Tac Toe uh but no
in all seriousness I I always say I
don't care that so much I accept that
computers are better than humans at
playing chess but will a computer ever
create a game like chess right once you
give it a set playground a Sandbox if
you will then yes it will exceed didn't
excel in certain capacities you know
right now I can't cross the road you
know I mean when I drive in a friend's
Tesla you know half the time it's it's
about to kill me and and I'm like how do
you you paid money for this little
feature I it's
$3,000 and it almost killed us and and
so and that's like the most advanced
system on now will it get better of
course and and you see these movies of
Boston Robotics and doing all C of crazy
Stu yes it's getting better it can sort
colors and it will get to be an
approximation and the question is is the
approxim at some level equal to The
Human Experience of Consciousness well
and can it ever get to the point where
it either can be programmed to or it can
somehow evolve to make voluntary
decisions yeah it's already doing that
right so the the reason that that open
AI did not have data before 2021 is
because that was when their first AI
foras were really starting to Blossom
and they were incredible and they were
doing great thing so now there's this
whole Corpus of of of of you know large
language products that have been
processed supervised by humans somewhere
at some point with some boundary
conditions but now so now you've got AIS
that are learning from what AIS have put
out but uh but it's not clear that
that's a convergent phenomenon that may
diverge you know I called it um mad bot
disease you know you remember mad cow
disease like cows eat other cows and
then they have these brain damage
effectively become zombie cows so when
Bots do that I mean they're already
inting even before they started to
access the web before 2021 so it's not
all clear that just scaling up this is
awesome I asked for a gluten-free recipe
for 16 people on a Thursday night in you
know the month of of May where you know
we want to have D whatever and it gave
it to me literally a second yeah it's
not at all clear that that scales up you
know uh completely once you start
feeding in the large language model
training and there may be you know kind
of sandb rather there may be
boundary fences put around it to prevent
the hallucination that's a h yeah yeah
and you actually said that you have both
a high degree of skepticism and the
belief that everything can be improved
and so what kinds of I don't know levels
of like scrutiny will we need to
implement with AI in scientific research
and education so there are a couple
things that I think uh I would feel
comfortable about applying AI you know
even as it is now and and those are
things like like refereeing papers uh
it's an incredibly thankless job that
these journals somehow only in the last
50 years I mean journals with peerreview
and we take it as the gold standard not
at all you know true or or or really
present couple of you know decades you
know before we were born so the fact
that it's sort of like oh only humans
can do this and that journals got people
like me to do their work you know paint
their fences for free never been
compensated even you know refering
nature articles and um you know taking
weeks of time to do it and very
thoughtful I think that llms can do a
tremendous amount of good there because
it's very prescribed very uh uh clear to
see what the boundary conditions are how
it can be used and how it could be uh
not to let it be abused and do things
like plagiarism searches uh look
searching for packing uh doing all the
sorts of like gut checks that scientists
don't really get to do because it's so
hard to to get the as you know to get
the funding to write the proposal get
the funding with a 12% acceptance rate
in in my field maybe lower in other
fields uh most people don't get their
first research Grant independently NIH
Grant until they're in their 40s uh and
you know it's not like oh well I have
kids when I'm 40 you know that wouldn't
have worked out so well um and so the
question is how do you actually make uh
these tools be of service to I think
clearcut and I read a study recently
from Cornell that uh actually you know
at least 30% of so I write a paper the
you know about the Big Bang model and
some new discovery that I made submit it
and then a person will referee it and
then an AI will referee it and then the
author will get the paper back and say
which one of these reports is is more
thorough more helpful and 30% already
like today this Cornell study showed are
better when the AI does it now wow not
50% or more but eventually it'll get
there and I think we can do away with
this you know kind of you know basic the
indentured servitude you know they Guilt
Trip us into refereeing their articles
that they can put behind a pay wall so I
think that's coming to an end I think
there'll be other ways to sort I think
we're going to get a lot of anything
where a blind you know kind of audition
so to speak applications to colleges um
those kinds of things submissions you
know um those can be reviewed and and
pre-processed and triage that's very
helpful so um and these things are just
fun like it's it's really fun to play
around you my artistic skill you know
were limited to like stick figures and
they still are um but nevertheless I I
am a da Vinci when it comes to using you
know Leonardo or or DOI or or whatever
and yeah that's been really fun for me
because you know especially making
YouTube content and I want to show you
know like what Elon Elon Musk claims he
wants to you know die on Mars so you
know I'll make a YouTube thumbnail of a
video where I'm talking with Joe Rogan
about you know Elon Musk and the
thumbnail be like an l elderly Elon Musk
you shuffling on Mars with a with a
space helmet with a Metamucil biscuit in
it yeah it's so much fun it really is
and I love to teach my kids how to use
it because I think they can get on board
really early in you know so- called
prompt engineering Which isos F I love
it yeah or even an art you know I've
heard it called prompt craft you know
yeah yeah the art of prompt craft I saw
a demo the other day that was a new
virtual reality application which I'm
sure a lot of people racing to do this
where you're literally walking through
essentially the holck and you're like I
want to be in a forest yeah and there it
is and I want the sky to be pink and now
I want a dragon flying through it and
now I want and I mean it's appearing as
you're saying it it's crazy it's just
wild well what do you think about AI as
it might impact the scientific method
you know you you've mentioned something
about this like that the somehow AI
could impact the scientific method to
make it better or it could impact it to
make it further from the
truth yeah I I think you know I think
the problem is that we really don't have
a uh a really coherent supervision
strategy of how we're going to really
supervise and and make sure that they're
aligned not the alignment of like human
flourishing that you know musk or you
know Sam Harris or somebody would talk
about um you know I'm not talking that
existential at this point but the same
time I think you know we want to treat
them and and and and have some caution
for H how we actually interact with them
understanding their limitations but I
think the bottlenecks again are going to
be just like in the aviation and medical
examples I I gave you before they're
going to be other humans they're going
to be the not the artificial
intelligence but the natural stupidity
you know and and the kind of pettiness
and and grievance you know kind of uh
Focus that we're going to have that
these things are you know taking our
jobs or these things are you know
putting people in danger etc etc so I I
do think that it's possible for us to to
go a little bit overboard and and feel
like yeah we these things are a net you
know just a net negative but but that
being said I think you know we do need
to have some sorts of safeguards I'm not
sure exactly what those should be but I
think they can be deployed in low-risk
environments like teaching you know as
I've already mentioned you know I feel
like there is very it's very difficult
for us to make a case that I am a better
Professor than Richard fean or than I'm
better than uh gallileo and these are
you know people are Sean or or um you
know Jane Goodall or you know so we have
access to thousands millions of words
written by these individuals the
greatest Educators in history and you
know we have like a master class with
Jane Goodall but but you but to take a
whole course and and really interact
with her and maybe use it to kind of as
they say you know flipping the classroom
I never really got into that um you know
I was more often getting flipped the
bird but but getting into it now I could
see it yeah you could really do a lot of
the work in problem solving um where uh
in the classroom with the
professor um but you could do and and
just ideation and and creativity and
Imagination in the classroom and then
you could do the kind of you know grunt
work oh here's this partial differential
equation and we need to solve it in
these boundary conditions and Etc I
think those could be done offline with a
with a again with Galileo or Fineman
teaching you how to do the you know
solve that equation they might not be so
good if you talk to them we set up a a
Fineman bot on my website banking.com
you can do a chat with my avatar bbot
I've taken my books put them in there
you can ask it what I think about aliens
or the Nobel Prize or Elon Musk and
it'll tell you and it's pretty accurate
it's not 100% accurate but um to kind of
do the heavy lifting of and sort of the
grunt where you know what it's like you
teach a you know if if you're teaching a
class and you have the choice between
teaching spelling or teaching you know
the works of Shakespeare it's always
more interesting to teach the more
advanced subject and this allows us to
shortcut that to get to the good stuff
with the students who are thirsty to get
to that as well yeah like you said get a
ton of prerequisites out of the way I
mean I love the idea of being able to
someday do statistics and just be able
to use regular language saying you know
how is group one different than group
two controlling for the following
variables and something come up in one
second like Oh Yes sounds amazing I
loved what you said earlier too about
like the in some ways we're just racing
toward the future like the technological
advancement is at light speed and then
in other ways it's really not I mean I
was using my air fryer the other day and
I was like this is the first time I kind
of feel like I'm living in the future
you know you just put something in it
you close the door you open it and it's
perfect but that's not very you know
that's not a big deal we thought we were
going to be flying on air you know
flying cars and cruising around on
meditating skateboards by now and you
know yeah we have uh look a tremendous
amount of Technology one of my friends
Eric Weinstein I've had him many times
on the podcast he said you know if you
were teleported you know from the 1950s
to today and you just showed up in the
living room you would say h the TVs are
flatter but almost nothing else would be
different right it would be essentially
unchanged now I mean that of course if
that's your whole domain yeah and I said
you know if you go to this apple picking
Orchard here in Julian California um you
will notice that nothing has changed
there's still you know people and kids
picking Apples by hand why haven't we
had you know robot lasers you know
zapping things and then the process no
that I mean some things will never you
know really improve upon there was a old
skit on Saturday Night Live called Deep
Thoughts with Jack Handy yeah I remember
that yeah you do I would think you're
too young but anyway I I I love it and
he had a book whoever it was writing it
and he said you know it's amazing to
think that the very first fly swatters
were nothing more than a stick with a
large thing at the end of it to kill fly
I'm like still is like that you know
right paper clips were once just wound
pieces of metal you know of course they
still are so the pace is slow on one
hand um software is cheap you know Mark
andreon has always said you know
software is eating the world and but if
you look at it you know the biggest
companies in the world are not software
companies they're you know
Tesla uh L Louis Vuitton um SpaceX and
they are Apple computer you know they're
not really open AI is is a blip open AI
is smaller than you know some
cryptocurrency you know perers right so
um so software is is great it's very
easy to produce software I'm not saying
it's easy you can produce a lot of it
and and then the question is you know
what sorts of you technical debt do you
have that you say oh I'm going to get to
this later I'm going to document this
later I'm going to patch this
hallucination feature now the stuff's
getting
real and I think you know people aren't
trusting it to like diagnose you know
tumors without
supervision but that can come you know
things that can be outsourced to things
that are better at scale and quantity
can sometimes I always say you know
quantity in certain amounts equates to
Quality yeah so you know the fact that
this thing can catch you know 0.1% with
a 0.1% error rate you know it's not 100%
and we'll never get to that but it's you
know it can do 100 thousand of those so
yes there'll be some and then those need
to be double checked so yeah it'll be
slow but again I think it's the law
industry law lawyer industrial complex
that's causing it a lot yeah I mean you
know there is that beer that this will
take our jobs but then I read an article
the other day that was like well what if
our job what if fulltime becomes three
days a week now that's a very about
meaning right meaning crisis you know
like how are we going to have you know
what's what's it going to mean are we
we're not all going to like sit around
and and write uh poetry right right and
you know I do feel like um there's just
a question you know when when the steam
engine came around people were put out
of business but you know when the plow
came around and the you know the tractor
there were plow you horses were put out
of business you know so the the ability
to generate and to retool a Workforce is
uh it is an interesting point I do feel
like you know thinking about things in
terms of like how much Leisure it will
give us I don't think that I personally
don't feel like that's the metric we
want to optimize I think you know people
can talk about some basic input and
basic income rather and so forth for the
neediest of cases but otherwise I think
people you know get a great deal of
meaning out of doing their labor their
work whatever it happens to be and and I
think we can use it in certain
industries to to improve life but to
think that it will happen in a vacuum
that we're going to have these robots
and we're simultaneously going to
increase minimum wage you know
incredibly just thinking first order
without really thinking about the
consequences of Downstream know a couple
of weeks later that's going to result in
you know just Mass layoffs where people
make zero dollars an hour so yeah um are
they all going to become you know uh
software engineers at Deep Mind I I
don't know u i I think a lot of this
will be addressed in some ways by
competition I I hope that we don't have
monopolistic like we did with browsers
or
computers I hope that there'll be and it
seems like there will be I mean I'm
surprised how at late you know it seems
like Amazon got into it given that they
had these devices I have one in the
background which I Chang its name so I
can say Alexa I Chang it to Cassie no no
I didn't I just Chang it to computer so
I can have computer turn off the plug
and they turn off the light behind me um
so these competitions I think will be
beneficial to the consumer love it well
my last question for you is um you know
that I have a strong interest in the
inner intersection between people's
spiritual experiences and spirituality
religion and health and well-being and
uh just like you were talking about
having the chat bots of some of the
scientific leaders I'm curious sometimes
about whether we can use AI to have
spiritual insights and to experience
things I mean certainly VR I think is uh
underutilized so far in not only being
able to maybe listen to meditation in
the morning but being able to go
meditate in a zendo with a teacher who's
amazing or a teacher who's died for that
matter yeah that kind of thing have you
ever had any thoughts about yeah I
worked a little bit here with Neil Smith
um over the summer who works in our
facility called the sun cave and uh he
was working on an artificial Gandhi that
then is a you know spiritual Guru right
as a world leader and and many great
thinker philosopher Etc and he was you
know basically took an you know Gandhi
didn't speak very much to he distrusted
video and so he there's not much of his
voice actually recorded and even less of
him on video uh he was very deeply
distrustful of it and so there's a
couple of minutes maybe 30 minutes or
less and Neil's gotten in his team of
undergraduates including my nephew who
work with him over the summer and they
took they digitized that they digitized
his his likeness his face but they made
it you know to avoid the uncanny Valley
effect they made them kind a little bit
a little bit cartoonish but they
actually imported it into Unreal Engine
it's is you know high quality video game
they M like his tunic with like
Beautiful Textures it's really a work of
art and you should contact him or maybe
for the summit next year we we'll
actually have a conversation you know
you and I can interview Gandhi let's do
it and it takes voice you dictate
transcribes to whisper uploads to chat
GPT Gandhi's whole Corpus of writings is
available answers the question then
there voice is synthesized and his lips
move accurately um now imagine that as
you said with not just dead gurus but
imagine you know my I could talk to my
late father yeah I would love that you
know I'd love to have a conversation
also with him they're not so much
digitized but but to have that
opportunity or like could it be possibly
a source of comfort you know not to
mention a business model but but it
could be that people you know upload
their avatars of their husbands and
instead of talking to you know strangers
on Snapchat they're talking to
their husband and or their wife or their
child God forbid so I I think these
things are have a great potential for
for for improvement they also can can
can be negative as you know but but I um
I'm an optimist I'm not worried about
getting turned into paper clips there's
not enough metal in a rocky planet of
the size of the Earth to create infinite
numbers of paper clips and I'm more
worried about uh you know human uh
stupidity or natural stupidity than
artificial intelligence or yeah great
okay well hey it's great to see you
Brian it's great to have you with us
thank you so much for taking the time
and where can people find you my website
Brian king.com and then YouTube Brian
keing pretty big Channel podcast into
the impossible and uh Twitter and
Instagram can find me there all right
sounds good great to see you thank you
so much for all your awesome work and
really glad to have you with us